hello stratford haven district council
is consulting on the preferred options
version of this site allocations plan
i'll be completely honest with you it's
not the most exciting topics but it is
very important we've prepared some
explanatory videos to try and break down
the plan into more manageable chunks
so hopefully you'll find these helpful
in this video i just wanted to provide
some background context
okay so why are we doing a site
allocations plan we already have a plan
for the district to 2031 called
core strategy and that meets our
development needs
however there are some things that the
core strategy doesn't cover and that's
where the science allocations plan comes
into play
the plan itself is split into eight
chapters chapter one
vegan introduction so chapter two looks
at reserve housing sites
these are signs to be brought forward if
they needed to maintain our housing
supply
or if additional housing needs arrived
before 2031.
self-build and custom-built housing
sites from chapter three
we're legally required to meet the needs
of those on our self-build register
so that's why i identify these chapter
four relates to defining built-up area
boundaries
for the villages to identify the areas
within the boundary
where new development is acceptable in
principle
chapter five is the new policy approach
to encouraging new employment sites to
boost our local economy
chapter six looks to safeguard land to
approve the a46 from funding allows
chapter seven contains 14 site-specific
proposals
right across the district for a mix of
uses that we think is appropriate to
plan for now
and will provide greater clarity for our
residents and communities
and lastly chap 8 contains all the maps
so you can see where the sites are there
are also some settlement maps on the
website so you can see all the site
proposals for that settlement
and see how they might affect you and
where you live
these videos along with the consultation
documents are available at
www.stratford.gov dot uk
slash sappo that's w www.stratford.com
s-a-p-p-o if you have any queries about
the conversation then please do email
planning dot policy stratfor hyphen
dc.gov dot uk
that's planning dot policy at stratford
hyphen vc.com
so the fundamental purpose of the site
allocations plan is to proactively set
out how we will continue to meet
the development challenges that our
district faces
if you disagree with our approach then
please do suggest what you think a
better alternative
is but these questions will still exist
even if we don't prepare a plan and your
comments are most helpful when framed in
this context
so please do fill out an interactive
form or send your comments to
policy dot consultation at stratford
hyphen dc dot dot dot uk
that's policy dot consultation at
stratford hyphen dc.gov dot
conservation closes at 5 pm on friday
the 18th of december
thanks very much for your time